- Failure's not a bad thing.
- Failure is the mother of all success.
- You should seek failures.
- No consideration of failure.
- You have to be able to
rise from the failure.
- Failure.
- Definition of failure.
- Getting things wrong is as important
as getting things right.
- Failure is on a success train.
- Hello Believe Nation.
Today we're going to talk about
how you can defeat failure.
And as always, guys, as
you're watching the videos,
if you see something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
And if you write it down
it's much more likely
to stick with yourself, as well.
- Yeah, I think failure's
the highway to success,
and I know that sounds like a platitude--
- [Woman] It is.
But society, where people teach us, right?
- [Woman] Um-hmm.
- They say, "Oh, if you
fail and feel uncomfortable,
you've done something wrong."
And what I try to do in all of my books,
and my presentations, and my tweets is,
you cannot get to the mountaintop
without taking a few missteps.
And so, a business that
wants to win, you have
to out-fail your competition.
And as human beings, you know,
failure's not a bad thing.
You know, ask yourself,
"What's the opportunity
from the failure?"
And get into the game, because
when you get to the last hour
of your last day, it will not
be the failures you regret,
it will be all the risks you didn't take.
- Eventually joined Harper's Bazaar U.S.,
and in 1976, it was, you were fired.
And I find that extraordinary.
No, they were very clear
in that they thought
that I would never undertstand
the American market.
I remember I was the editor on one shoot
that was, I think it was
French fashion shows,
and I decided that it would be interesting
to have dreadlocks on the models,
and I think that that pushed them further
than they could bear.
So that was it for me, but you know,
I think it's always part of
life to have some knocks,
as well as some successes--
- And to take risks.
- And, you know, to learn,
so I think it's healthy
for everyone to lose a job
as well as to gain a job.
- I came upon a slogan, and I tell it
to my kids all the time,
I say, "There's no losing,
only learning, there's no
failure, only opportunities,
and there's no problems, only solutions."
So to me what failure
is, failure is the mother
of all success.
If it wasn't for Michael
Jordan getting cut
From his 9th grade basketball team,
he wouldn't have became Michael Jordan.
You know, if it wasn't for, I
seen an article the other day,
where they were talking
about Oprah Winfrey,
and how she got fired,
because she wasn't good for television.
You know, you got people like Walt Disney,
who got fired and comments
from a newspaper saying
he had no imagination.
(in foreign language)
These are the same people
that I've got to deal
with telling me what's not a hit record.
So--
- [Man] So what do you tell them,
do you tell them, you know--
- You know that all they can do is learn,
and come back bigger, better, stronger.
Cause all it's going to do is
lead you in the right direction.
See, if you're always winning,
then you don't really
understand what it is to win.
You got to take those losses,
you got to take those hits.
There's got to be the values
the peaks, the ups, the downs,
in order for you to, when it does happen,
you go, "Wow, (in foreign language)."
You know, this is what's it's all about.
And not only that,
it's never about making it, guys,
it's always about maintaining it.
That's the toughest part.
- You should seek failures.
See, if you're playing it
safe, you're not going to win.
If you're playing it safe,
like that old saying, you know,
you were taught when
you were a little girl,
"Better to be safe than sorry."
Well, that's a bunch of crap.
It's not better to be safe than sorry.
It's by trying things
that you figure out how far you can go.
You've got to get outside the box.
Like it's reported,
Edison tried 3,000 ways
before he built the incandescent light.
He said, he didn't fail 3,000 times,
he said there was 3,000 different steps
to building a light bulb.
Well, there's different steps
to get where you're going.
And I really do treat winning
and losing exactly the same.
I do not let it upset me.
- Do you think that's a big part
of why you're so successful?
- Well, it's part of why I enjoy it.
Yeah, I think it is,
cause I'll try anything.
Like, if I'm into an idea,
the idea of losing never enters my mind.
See, I have worked with giants.
I had the good fortune of
working with Sir Edmund Hillary.
He was the first man to
stand on top of the world.
And I worked with him on
three different occasions.
And the only difference in
Ed Hillary and Bob Proctor,
is his size.
Now he's gone now, but he was a big man.
When he shook hands with me,
his hand wrapped right around mine.
I felt like a dwarf, you know.
And, in talking to him, like
it never entered his mind
he wouldn't get to the
top of the mountain,
but he failed in 1951, he failed in 1952,
and it wasn't until 1953
that he got to the top
of the mountain.
You know, people had died for
centuries trying to do that.
But he said I knew if
I could see it in here,
I could hold it out here.
Stella Mann wrote that in
a book, "If you can see it
in your head, you can
hold it in your hand."
And that's right, and if
you're not prepared to lose,
you're never going to win,
because you're always playing it safe,
and there's no reward in that.
- I've always had this really
gross, dangerous mentality
of no consideration of failure.
Just never even considering
the thought of failing.
Like if I want something,
I just go until I get it.
And that doesn't always work, but...
- I think, like you said,
every single artist goes through that,
and I think a lot of times you think
that the great writers are the people,
they just write hit, after hit, after hit.
And they do, but it's also
because they get through all
the terrible songs first,
and I think that's kind of
every single artist's story.
I mean, I love to tell, when people ask,
"What's you best advice for,
you know, upcoming musician,
or anybody," I think it's that
you have to be able to rise
from the failures, is what
makes a successful person.
Because everybody's going to have mishaps.
They're going to fall down,
and it's, you know, the people
that continuously pick themselves up
that are the ones that are
going to find their voice,
make it, whatever you want to call it.
- I mean, I'm pretty sure
there are people who,
you know, had their doubts.
As I say, you know, art is subjective.
Some people have an
opinion they like about it,
and of course, they have,
they're entitled to,
because they're paying their money for it.
But, you know, I never let that stop me.
I've always been able to
turn my head into great,
and not really accept any
down moments, low peaks,
as a failure, but yet, a
lesson, to teach me how
to be better, stronger,
more wise, and resilient.
You know, I really have never
gotten to the negative stuff.
I just, I don't really absorb it.
- As an entrepreneur,
there actually is a definition of failure.
And a lot of people ask
me, "When you move on,"
when do you stop what you're doing,
and say, "Maybe this isn't working out?"
And I like to say, "Well,
first you have to believe in,
if you keep believing in what
you're doing, keep going."
But there's one other criteria.
If keeping going means you are going
to do severe physical or
mental damage to yourself,
then you should move on.
- [Man] Yeah.
- And my last company, I
sort of got to that point.
It was a success for me, I
mean, I ultimately sold it
to a large company out
of Boston called Akamai,
but I was at that point
where I had gone seven years,
and it was really hard times,
and I knew that if I had kept going
in this little blip of
success we started to see,
if that was a mirage, I
knew I would kind of go,
I would start to go crazy, like for real.
Failure is when, is maybe when,
at least I feel like I failed
when I didn't put everything
I had into a problem.
So really, it goes back
to the analogy I made at the beginning.
If you don't put it all out there,
if you don't put everything
you got into solving a problem,
then that's failure.
- Overall, that very thumbnail sketch
of a very interesting and
a very inspiring life,
what do you think you've learned most,
what would you do
differently, in other words.
- Do you know, I wouldn't
do anything differently,
because I think getting things wrong,
as we've just talked
about, is as important
as getting things right.
So I wouldn't change
anything because actually,
I have learned a lot.
And the thing that I've
learned is, I know what I value
in life, I know what's important to me,
I know what I want to spend my time doing,
I know the differences
that I want to make,
and more important,
I absolutely know what I don't want to do.
- I'm not going to do
what everybody else does,
I'm just going to do what I want to do,
because life's too short,
and I can't live up
to other people's expectations.
I can only do what I can
deliver in this life.
So I put that on my wrist
to remind me all times,
that, like, trust in self.
And you know, I will up.
Doesn't mean I'm flawless.
I made "Cop Out" and
"Jersey Girl," so you know,
you can things up but you can
learn from that, you know.
There's no such thing as absolute failure,
except sitting there and not trying.
That's absolute failure,
but even if you fail
at something, failure
is on a success train,
because you learn how to
do it better the next time.
As long as you try again, you're smarter
than the average bear.
Some people kind of try
something that falls apart,
and they walk away.
- Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed, I'd love to know,
what did you think of the video?
Which clip had the biggest
impact on you and why?
Leave in the comments below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to blackpearls87, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, "Your One Word,"
and posting that picture on Twitter.
I hope you're enjoying it
and I appreciate the support.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself, and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.